what tips do you have for looking great
on Zoom meetings and so even if
someone's not a content creator yet and
I think about even the think media team
we try we're all remote there's almost
30 of us with contractors now and our
team is growing and we are trying to
build culture for a remote workplace and
so that can be hard to do we're trying
to say hey have your camera on and so
what are some tips maybe for looking
great on Zoom meetings connecting on
Zoom meetings and for leaders trying to
lead remote team yes so that's most of
my folks so um how to look good on
camera how to lead with influence on
video Is My Jam so and these go for
creators or Zoom meetings or video
presentations first is the first 10
words you say what are those first 10
words making them purposeful and second
is how you say those first 10 words so
let's start with the how the biggest
mistake that people make on video is
they start when they're most anxious so
when we're nervous we're waiting for our
Zoom to pop up or we're waiting for our
camera to be on we taking a deep breath
like this and we say hi hey
everyone at the very top of our breath
it's when we're most nervous so when we
analyze all these video calls we notice
that people give away their vocal
confidence in the first 10 seconds
typically it's because they start really
high in their vocal C they start really
high in their vocal range this is for
both men and women so right now I'm
working very hard to use the lowest end
of my natural range I'm going to tighten
my vocal cord so you can hear what it
sounds like when I'm anxious or a little
bit nervous I tend to go higher into my
range I also get a little bit of vocal
fry so when I'm anxious or nervous I
tend to sound like this now imagine if I
were to give an entire presentation in
this tone of voice it would drive you
crazy and that is because we hear the
anxiety and we're like no so what
happens is we're most nervous the very
beginning of our call and so we start up
there so what I want you to make sure of
is you do not hold your breath on your
first few words right so instead of
hello good to see everyone I want you to
make sure you're speaking on the out
breath so hey good to see everyone those
are two totally different vocal
Impressions and the first 10 seconds of
a video you're going to lose someone
you're GNA get someone that's high
warmth and high competence so speak on
the out breath do not hold your breath
second do not ask your name it's such a
silly one but research shows I can even
talk to you about the doctor study if
you want but research shows that when we
ask a statement it triggers someone to
go from listening to scrutinizing so if
I were to sayhe my name is Vanessa I am
a YouTuber and I write
books you immediately think of me as
less competent and that's because I'm
asking things that should be said so I
want you to go back and listen to a
couple Zoom meetings or listen to a
couple of your recent videos and
identify every single time you ask a
statement that's going up at the end of
your sentence every time you do that
you're giving away a little bit of your
vcal power you're giving away a little
bit of your bical confidence so I want
you to state your name and not rush
through it so that happens a lot on
videos I am guilty of this I'm working
on the rushing through I have a long
name Vanessa van Edwards and I used to
be like V of words because it made me
nervous to say it so slow down your name
state your name don't ask it so that's
the how um there are about 15 different
vocal cues that you want to think about
if you're doing a lot of video but those
are the two most important ones the
second thing is the kinds of words you
use most people throw away the first 10
words they say ES especially in a zoom
call typically the first 10 words
someone says is I can't see I can you
can you see me can you hear me high up
all question reflection throwing away
the words so Sean we first hopped on I
made sure I said hello I was going to
see you and then I asked if you like my
microphone right and then I was like do
you like the way it sounds so your first
10 words should be very purposeful they
should be something warm and competent
hey I'm so honored to be here I can't
wait wait to meet everyone on this
meeting right like even as simple as
that it makes you sound positive it sets
up the meeting for Success it is so
critical that we don't also accidentally
start negative oh this weather man sorry
I'm late that traffic um hold on hold on
let me just get my coffee uh we're gonna
wait for everyone to log on when we
check our
email no no more no more purposeful
Impressions only please man these are
such powerful nuances because there's
challenges that we have with being in
remote teams and building culture has
its own challenges and so you're trying
to do a lot in terms of tone energy
emotion and so these are some very
practical te uh things before we move on
what about looking great on video and
for anybody you coach or encourage do
you encourage people to invest in decent
equipment or a decent microphone or even
if they just have their MacBook in
webcam and airpods any tips for showing
up great on video yes so um I really
recommend a real background research
actually shows we do not like fake
backgrounds it's very distracting to the
eye we also see it as a little bit
inauthentic our brain cannot help but
wonder what's back there and also you
cannot control when you raise your hand
up and your hands disappear it is so
distracting for the brain so please I
would even more than lighting I would
rather you get a real background like
that's a real background behind me right
so please real background I would rather
have a plain real wall like literally a
plain wall then a fake background I
would even if I had to choose pick a
somewhat dirty living room over a
virtual one and that's saying a lot now
hopefully you don't have dirty living
room but real so real background um that
really helps you look better seriously
um second is I think investing in gear
is okay but one is I would make sure
that it's you're fronting so you're
angling your body towards the camera too
often I see people wear their cameras
off to their side and they're typing
like this that's actually a
disrespectful non-verbal cue when you're
angled away so make sure that wherever
your camera is it's in line with your
toes right so it's in line with your
toes um please do away with swivel
chairs unless you can help but not
swivel in them so I'm standing right now
because I'm a naughty swiveler um when
I'm on video so I do not let myself sit
down when I'm on video um so if you can
stand that definitely helps you deliver
better it helps you look better um
swivel chairs are
distracting and oh yes eyeline so um
there's a lot of research now that's
looking at where our angle is so if you
look up at someone typically it's um you
do see that person as more confident
because they look taller and bigger but
actually if you want to have an equal
relationship with someone I highly
recommend having your camera at eye
level so my camera is exactly at eye
level like to the to the inch so if you
can get at eye level try not to go down
or up so it doesn't have to be expensive
gear it's actually all about the
positioning these tips are gold because
there are some small tweaks that we can
make to our current setups to connect
better and man as professionals maybe
we're in a selling situation we're in a
coaching situation we're in a Content
creation situation even camera placement
could power up our next video or have us
make an better impression in our
workplace virtually I really am curious
though you you've coined the carot the
Charisma formula that has cues from D
Vinci's Last Supper and highlights the
non-verbal cues of some powerful figures
what is the Charisma formula yeah so the
Charisma formula is warmth cues plus
competence cues so there are 96 cues and
I break them down into warm competent
charismatic there are a few cues that
are so good they hit the balance and
then danger zone and danger zone cues
are like don't do these they're Negative
they show guilt or deception and you
don't want to do them um so what's
interesting is I think these cues are
everywhere and I think they often
explain why things go viral what's the
original viral image the last supper
right it's like one of the most known
images in the world and I think it's
because it holds some really intrinsic
Universal cues there are cultural cues
but there's some Universal cues so for
example um I I spent a lot of time
looking at this image and breaking down
all the cues that are in it the very
simplest is that if you measure the
amount of space each person in that
picture takes up Christ takes up the
most amount of space and we recognize
this as a universal gesture of Pride so
research from un University of British
Columbia found that across cultures and
genders and races when we feel pride and
we feel confidence we take up space
usually have space between our torso and
our arms so a thing to think about for
YouTube is um you know Amy cudy back in
the day did a TED Talk where she talked
about power power posing I like power
posing but like I'm not going to power
pose in my videos I'm I'm not going to
be like I'm here everyone right I'm not
going to stand with my arms wide but
what's more important is actually the
distance between our torso and our arms
so the way that I have my setup is that
I almost always have space between my
torso and my arms and I also have
maximized the distance between my
earlobes and my shoulder so we're taking
up as much space as possible so in the
Last Supper Christ is not only taking up
the most amount of space but he has his
arms planted wide he has space between
his shoulders and his torsone he has
space between his ear loves and his
shoulder that's how you should sit on
Zoom honestly if you're on Zoom or
you're a Creator just like Channel
Christ in the Last Supper be like what
was Christ doing then that's what I
should do he also is showing a a head
tilt so a head tilt is a universal
warmth cue and that is because when
we're trying to hear someone better we
go what' you say and we tilt our head to
expose our ear and so while he's the
most powerful posture wise he is also
showing warmth and that is the sweet
spot for leadership we like people who
show a balance of warmth cues and
competence cues deep insights you know
one of the most important aspects of
content creation is the visuals and of
course there's the colors of thumbnails
people actually get really geeky in the
science of thumbnails color Choice um
and then there's even what we could wear
on our videos how we edit our videos
what are some tips for the psychology of
color IM and profile picture pictures
and this could extend to our marketing
materials our branding and how this
comes into play when it comes to cues so
first is I think I am terrible at
imagery on YouTube so this is the first
thing is do not look at my videos for
any imagery cues I am terrible with it
that is because for many years I was
doing my own visual cues and I am a
teacher I am not a designer so do not
look at my channel for any of those tips
however what we did break down for cues
is the color cues as well as ornament
cues so the way that you want to think
about ornament cues that last category
of cues is associations neural
associations so when someone sees a
political flag on a lapel right if I
were on this video and I was wearing an
American flag of my lapel you would
immediately think of politics right like
even if I didn't talk about politics
somehow you'd be thinking that I was
political possibly even right leaning
possibly right so what you want to think
of is what are the ornaments saying so
for example in the back of Sean's video
we have tools like a hammer right which
immediately triggers me to think
practical actionable like getting into
it I also see his award which is a
credibility marker which means wow like
he's someone I want to learn from he's a
someone I want to Aspire to be he's
really successful on YouTube he also has
a couple of plants which shows a little
bit of warmth right so all of those cues
are subconsciously associate having
neural associations for me so when I
picked my background because we could
have done a a a back like a back screen
like a backdrop is that they call them
behind me I was like no I want it to be
um super clean Super crisp and I want to
show real trees that's all I want real
trees and so that's something that I
like you to focus on my content you have
something kind of relaxing behind you
that's how I picked this I also for many
years taught in a studio with my
favorite chemicals behind me oxytocin
serotonin and dopamine and that's
because I use them as teaching AIDS so
not only I would I know they were
creating neural associations to science
and my is called science people my
YouTube channel is called science people
so I was trying to double up on those
neural associations to my channel and my
branding but also it was great because
I'd be like oxytocin dopamine serotonin
and it was like a timesaver for me and
my editor did not have to add those
images so I would say whatever you're
creating it just has to have the right
purposeful neural associations there are
no bad there's no bad color to wear on
YouTube there's no bad color to put in
your thumbnails it's all about what
associations they're bringing up for
your viewers so very interesting now you
also did an experiment on Shark Tank and
what was a surprising finding that you
got from Shark Tank in relationship to
Q's so um I love Shark Tank and again I
was always kind of curious if there were
patterns if you could more so could you
predict a winning pitch by just watching
the first few minutes like if you were
just to watch the it's all cut right
it's usually an hour and a half pitch
it's synthesized and or eight minutes
but could you predict just watching the
first minute who was going to win or who
was going to lose and there was some
really clear variables or clear um
patterns that we saw with the most
likely to win pitches they weren't in
every winning pitch but they tended to
be winning pitches so the first one was
typically some kind of non-verbal
greeting so typically the most
successful pitchers literally physically
greeted the chks they'd be like hey or
uh good morning like they would do some
sort of open Palm gesture to the Sharks
listening I think that was a a warmth
cue but B these sharks are hearing you
know dozens of pitches in a day I think
when they felt acknowledged even
subconsciously they were like ah
friendly like I can trust this person so
some sort of non-verbal greeting I do
this from stage do this on video I think
it's really important um the second
thing that we thought was thought was
really surprising is um interactivity of
the pitch helps predict a winning pitch
so having them touch a product smell a
product taste a product play a game and
you'll notice earlier I had us all play
a game where I had us lean in that is
interaction right that is something
that's going to switch someone from just
listening to actually interacting with
the person and so I've taken that in
almost all of my videos I try at least
if it's longer than five minutes to do
some kind of interactivity if I can
that's amazing some of my favorite talks
um they get the audience involved do
this with your hands do this with your
neighbor stand on your feet and those
become very memorable so those those are
some fascinating insights my my talks
always you know we're not talking about
stage presence but um my talks that is
the critical thing is I want people to
be literally I'm changing modes every 30
seconds on stage so you don't have time
to check your email you're you're you're
with me in every mode switch from stage
if you enjoyed this content and want to
take your YouTube channel to the next
level just click or tap the link on the
screen or go to tube 1K challenge.com to
join our next live YouTube challenge
you'll learn our best tips and
strategies that are working here at
think media and I think you'll love it